IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
JOE BIDEN FINALLY BREAKING HIS
SILENCE AND DENYING THAT HE EVER
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED HIS FORMER
SENATE AIDE TARA READE.
>> IT IS NOT TRUE.
I AM SAYING UNEQUIVOCALLY, AND
NEVER, NEVER HAPPENED.
AND IT DIDN’T.
I’M NOT GOING TO QUESTION HER
MOTIVE.
I’M NOT GOING TO GET INTO THAT
AT ALL.
I DON’T KNOW WHY SHE IS SAYING
THIS, I DON’T KNOW WHY AFTER 27
YEARS ALL OF A SUDDEN THIS GETS
RAISED.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND IT, BUT I’M
NOT GOING TO GO IN AND QUESTION
HER MOTIVE.
I’M NOT GOING TO ATTACK HER.
SHE HAS A RIGHT TO SAY WHATEVER
SHE WANTS TO SAY, BUT I HAVE A
RIGHT TO SAY, LOOK AT THE FACTS.
CHECK IT OUT.
FIND OUT WHETHER ANY OF WHAT SHE
SAYS IS ASSERTED OR TRUE.
>> Juan: BIDEN ALSO UNDER
PRESSURE TO RELEASE SENATE
RECORDS, HIS ACCUSER SAYS COULD
SHOW THAT SHE FILED A COMPLAINT
BACK IN 1993.
THE FORMER VP SAYS HIS
CONFIDENCE A COMPLAINT DOES NOT
EXIST IN THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
OR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE
WHERE HIS SENATE RECORDS ARE
BEING HELD.
>> I AM ABSOLUTELY POSITIVE THAT
NO ONE I AM AWARE OF EVER HAS
BEEN MADE AWARE OF ANY
COMPLAINT, FORMER COMPLAINT MADE
BY TARA READE AGAINST ME.
AT THE TIME THIS ALLEGEDLY
HAPPENED 27 YEARS AGO.
THE RECORD CAN ONLY BE ONE
PLACE.
IT WOULD NOT BE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE, MY
ARCHIVES DO NOT CONTAIN PERSONAL
FILES.
MY ARCHIVES CONTAIN DOCUMENTS,
AND WHEN I SAY PERSONNEL, I MEAN
PERSONNEL FILES.
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP
WEIGHING IN ON THE BIDEN ALLEGAT
>> I WOULD SAY TO JOE BIDEN,
JUST GO OUT AND FIGHT IT.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
BUT SHE IS FAR MORE CONVINCING
THAN FORD OR THE OTHER THREE
THAT I THINK HAVE ALREADY
RECANTED.
>> Juan: DANA, I JUST WANTED
TO START WITH YOU AND SAY, DO
YOU THINK THAT JOE BIDEN DID A
GOOD JOB?
>> Dana: I THINK THAT HE
PROBABLY DID BETTER THAN HIS
TEAM WAS THINKING, BUT YOU KNOW,
THEY HAD FIVE WEEKS TO PREPARE.
I THINK THAT WAITING FOR THE
MEDIA FRENZY TO GET TO SUCH A
HIGH FEVER PITCH THAT YOU HAD IT
WITH THE NEW YORK TIMES THAT
SHAMING THEM AND NOT DOING AN
INTERVIEW.
I THINK THAT MSNBC HAD A TOUGH
QUESTION FOR HIM, I DON’T THINK
ANYBODY COULD SAY THAT THERE WAS
A SUPER EASY INTERVIEW FOR HIM.
HE OPENED HIMSELF UP FOR SOME
SKEPTICISM ON THIS POINT UP OUT
OF THE DOCUMENTS, THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVE SAYING, WE DON’T HAVE
THOSE, THAT WOULD BE IN YOUR
PERSONAL PAPERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE, AND IT
IS SURPRISING KNOWING FOR FIVE
WEEKS THAT THIS WAS COMING THAT
THEY HAVE NOT GONE TO THE
UNIVERSITY, ASKED FOR THE FULL
INVESTIGATION, AND ABLE TO
PRODUCE OR NOT PRODUCE IT.
SO THEY ARE VULNERABLE ON A
COUPLE OF POINTS.
AND THEN ON THE SUBSTANCE OF IT,
OF COURSE, VULNERABLE ON THE
WHOLE POINT ABOUT THE HYPOCRISY.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT POLITICS
AND HYPOCRISY GO HAND-IN-HAND,
AND IF YOU ARE ACCUSED OF
HYPOCRISY SAYING ONE THING ABOUT
THE CANDIDATE YOU SUPPORT AND
THEN SOMETHING ELSE AGAINST AN
OPPONENT OF THAT CANDIDATE, THEN
YOU CAN ALWAYS RATIONALIZE THAT,
YOU CAN BRING IT UP.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE LOCKED THEMSELVES INTO THIS
CORNER, AND TARA REID SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO COME FORWARD, SHE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO DO
INTERVIEWS.
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
I DON’T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WILL
HAPPEN NEXT, BECAUSE, THEY ARE
CALLING FOR AN INVESTIGATION OF
SOME SORT, BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THE NEXT BATTLE IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS, AND LET ME
JUST SAY ONE OTHER THING.
RIGHT NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE ALL
STANDING BEHIND JOE BIDEN, AND
YOU HAVE NOT HEARD MUCH FROM
THEM IN THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS.
IF YOU ARE THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL
SHORT CANDIDATES HAVE SAID THAT
THEY HAVE SUPPORTED HIM.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS THAT JOE BIDEN
IS JOE BIDEN.
BUT IF YOU START TO SEE ANY
HIGH-PROFILE DEMOCRATS START TO
WALK AWAY OR SHOW A LITTLE BIT
OF DAYLIGHT BETWEEN JOE BIDEN
AND TO THEM, I THINK THAT YOU
WILL SEE A WHOLE RASH, AND AT
THAT POINT WE MIGHT BE WATCHING
SOME REALLY INTERESTING HISTORY
UNFOLD AS WE ARE 26 WEEKS AWAY
FROM THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
>> Juan: WELL, JESSE, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT THROUGH
THIS KIND OF THING, HE DENIED
IT.
SO NOW YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN
DENYING ONE ALLEGATION, NOT A
PATTERN, BUT ONE.
DO YOU TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD THE
WAY YOU TOOK PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
HIS WORD?
>> Jesse: YEAH, I MEAN, YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THE PERSON AT THEIR
WORD, BUT YOU ALSO JUST HAVE TO
FIND THE FACTS.
AND THEY HAVE NOT REALLY
INVESTIGATED THIS THE WAY THAT
THEY DID INVESTIGATE BOSSI FORD,
I MEAN, TO DANA’S POINT, IF I
HAD FIVE WEEKS TO PREPARE FOR
ONE INTERVIEW, BOOM, HOME RUN.
I WOULD GIVE JOE MAY BE A STAND
UP DOUBLE HERE, I THOUGHT THAT
HIS TONE WAS GOOD, AND HIS
MANNER WAS STRONG, BUT I DON’T
KNOW IF HE CONVINCED ANYBODY
EITHER WAY.
VOTERS ARE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
NEVER KNOW THE TRUTH AND FACTOR
IT INTO THEIR DECISION IN
NOVEMBER.
HE LEFT HIMSELF VULNERABLE FOR
SURE WHEN IT WAS ASKED WHETHER
HE REMEMBERED READE, HE DODGED,
AND HIS OBVIOUS CAVANAUGH
STANDARD ABOUT BELIEVE ALL WOMEN
HAS EVOLVED.
IT’S NOW BELIEVE ALL WOMEN AT
FIRST, AND THEN AND INVESTIGATE
THEM.
NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD THINK
INVESTIGATE AND THEN BELIEVE, I
AM NOT SURE WHAT HE BELIEVES.
I JUST THINK HE KNOWS THAT HE
NEEDS TO SAY WHAT HE NEEDS TO
SAY TO GET OUT OF THAT QUESTION.
THE RECORDS THING REALLY OPENS
UP A CAN OF WORMS.
FIRST, IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAY
THAT THERE ARE SENATE RECORDS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS NOT SEEN, WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
SETTLED MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
LAWSUITS AND DONE TONS OF
PAYOUTS, WHAT MAKES YOU THINK WE
WILL JUST LOOK AT JOE’S RECORD?
WHAT ABOUT THE CURRENT SENATORS,
HOW FAR BACK AND YOU GO?
AND THE DELAWARE THING, WE ARTY
KNOW THAT THE OPERATIVES SNUCK
IN THERE AND WERE SQUIRRELING
AWAY RECORDS AND THEY GOT CAUGHT
BY BUSINESS INSIDER.
IT’S LIKE REMEMBER SANDY BERGER,
THEY CALLED HIM SANDY BURGLAR
WITH STUFFING DOCUMENTS IN HIS
PANTS AFTER THE CLINTONS MISSED
IT, I CAN SEE THAT HAPPENING.
BUT WHY DID JOE BIDEN SAY THAT
IN HIS PERSONAL RECORD THERE
WERE TRANSCRIPTS OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT HE HAD WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
WHY WOULD HE SAY THAT?
YOU DON’T THINK THE PRESIDENT
WILL TURN UP THE HEAT AND SAY,
JOE, RELEASE THE TRANSCRIPT, I
RELEASED MINE, MINE WAS PERFECT,
WHAT ABOUT YOURS?
SO THIS IS NOT GOING AWAY
ANYTIME SOON.
>> Juan: GREG, TAKE A LISTEN,
HERE’S JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
>> THEY COULD COME FORWARD AND
SAY SOMETHING ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED TO HIM, THEY
SHOULD START OFF WITH THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THEY ARE
TELLING THE TRUTH, THEN YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THEN THE FACTS, AND THE FACTS
ARE THAT THEY DO NOT EXIST.
THEY NEVER HAPPENED.
AND THERE ARE SO MANY
INCONSISTENCIES IN WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID IN THIS CASE.
I SAID DURING THE CAVANAUGH
HEARINGS WAS THAT SHE HAD A
RIGHT TO BE HEARD, AND THE FACT
THAT SHE CAME FORWARD, THE
PRESUMPTION WOULD BE THAT SHE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH UNLESS IT IS
PROOF THAT SHE WAS NOT TELLING
THE TRUTH.
>> Juan: SO GREG, DOES THIS
GIVE THE DEMOCRATS COVER HOLDING
TO THE STANDARD THAT PEOPLE NOW
HAVE HEARD FROM TARA REID?
AND NOW JOE BIDEN HAS SPOKEN ON
TARA REID?
>> Greg: I WILL TAKE BIDEN AT
HIS WORD, I PRESUME THAT SHE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID.
THEY HAVE NOT DISPROVEN IT.
SO WE HAVE TO PRESUME THAT SHE
IS TELLING THE TRUTH.
LOOK, BIDEN WAS DOING GREAT IN
THAT INTERVIEW UNTIL HE
CONFESSED.
YOU KNOW, FIRST HE HAS A TOTAL
DENIAL.
THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
THE DENIAL WAS STRONG, AND THEN
HE SAID AT THE COMPLAINT, YOU
KNOW, I DON’T KNOW WHY ALL OF A
SUDDEN, 27 YEARS, THIS GETS
RAISED.
WHAT IS THIS?
THAT IS INTERESTING.
I WILL PURSUE THAT, AND BRINGING
UP A LOT OF THE COOPERATING,
VERY TOUGH WORD TO SAY,
COOPERATING WITH EVIDENCE.
WHAT ABOUT THE PHONE CALL, I
THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING, THAT
WAS AROUND THE ’90s.
WHAT IS FUN IS WATCHING THE PRO
BIDEN RESPONSE WHICH IS WORD FOR
WORD WHAT THEIR SIDE WOULD HAVE
MOCKED WHEN PRESENTED IN DEFENSE
OF KAVANAUGH, SO THEY ARE
APOPLECTIC OVER A SINGLE VIEW
CANDIDATE, THE KAVANAUGH THING
WHY YOU CAN’T COMPARE IT WENT
FOR DAYS.
HE WAS GRILLED BY TEAMS OF
SALIVATING LAWYERS.
AND IT IS RUFFLED WITH ONE
SEGMENT, SHUT UP, YOU ARE A
BUNCH OF HYPOCRITES.
AGAIN, THE ARGUMENT WILL ALWAYS
BE ABOUT CONSISTENCY.
EVERYONE HAS BROUGHT IT UP, BUT
IF YOU SAY BELIEVE ALL WOMEN
COMING TO HAVE TO DESTROY
JOE BIDEN, SO THEORETICALLY HE
HAS TO TAKE HIMSELF OUT UNLESS
HE SAYS, THIS WHOLE BELIEVE ALL
WOMEN THING ONLY SUITS US
POLITICALLY, SO I’M ACTUALLY NOT
A HARASSER, I’M JUST A SHAMELESS
HYPOCRITE THAT WILL RUIN YOU
POLITICALLY GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY, LASTLY, I WOULD
NOTICE AN EPIDEMIC OF PEOPLE
GETTING HOISTED BY THEIR OWN
PETARD, THAT IS A BOX THAT HOLDS
A BALL GLOVE.
AND de BLASIO GETS BUSTED FOR
WANTING PEOPLE TO NARC ON
OTHERS.
NUMBER TWO, YOU SAW THE ONES
THAT TRIED TO FRAME MICHAEL
FLYNN, FRAMING THEMSELVES, AND
NOW YOU HAVE A GUY WHO IS RIGHT
UP THERE WITH METOO AND
KAVANAUGH GETTING METOO-ED BY
HIMSELF.
LOOK, A SPIDER DOING PUSH-UPS.
ISN’T THAT FUN?
IT’S FRIDAY.
>> Juan: KATIE, THE
VICE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT A
WOMAN WILL BE HIS
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CHOICE, HE HAS
NAMED THE PANEL THIS WEEK, WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY, THE DENIAL, THE
WHOLE EPISODE, IS THAT GOING TO
IMPACT TO THE CHOICE IS?
I THINK RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE
SENATOR HARRIS,
SENATOR KLOBUCHAR,
SENATOR WARREN, AND FORMER HOUSE
REPS, STACY ABRAMS FROM GEORGIA.
>> Katie: FIRST I THINK THE
NEWS THAT CAME OUT OF THIS
INTERVIEW TODAY IS NOT THAT HE
DENIED IT, BECAUSE THAT WAS
OBVIOUS, WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED TO
SAY, LET’S MOVE ON, OF COURSE HE
WAS GOING TO DO THAT, BUT HE WAS
FINALLY ASKED ABOUT IT, AND THE
PRESIDENT HAD BEEN ASKED
MULTIPLE TIMES BEFORE JOE BIDEN
WAS ASKED ABOUT IT.
THAT’S THE FIRST THING.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THE MEDIA DOES
NOT JUST LET IT GO, BECAUSE OF
ONE INTERVIEW ABOUT HIS RESPONSE
TO IT.
BUT TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, A
LOT OF THESE WOMEN WHO ARE ON
THE SHORT-LIST, APPARENTLY
APPARENTLY FOR THIS POSITION
WERE WORSE THAN JOE BIDEN WHEN
IT COMES TO WHAT THEY SAID ABOUT
BRETT KAVANAUGH AND DUE PROCESS.
AND I THINK THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, WHAT THEY SAID IN
THEIR STATEMENT ABOUT TO THE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN’S RECORD ON
THIS ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
COLLEGE CAMPUSES OF YOUNG MEN
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY IN THE
STANDARD THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION APPLIED TO
ACCUSATIONS ON CAMPUS, AND WOULD
HAVE BEEN EXCELLED AND KICKED
OUT OF CAMPUS RIGHT NOW, IF YOU
TAKE THE STATEMENTS THAT HIS
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
MADE AS WOMEN AND APPLY IT TO
THE RECORD OF VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AND SAY, ON ONE SIDE WOMEN
WHO HAVE VALID CLAIMS ARE
DISMISSED AND IGNORED, OR MEN
ARE FALSELY ACCUSED, AND IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA, BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS ARE BAD.
SO I THINK THAT PEOPLE JUST FEEL
BAD ABOUT IT AND THEY WANT TO
MOVE ON.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW, KATIE, DOES
THAT MEAN THAT YOU THINK THIS
HAS BEEN A SETBACK FOR THE
#Me Toomovement?
>> Katie: COMPLETELY, BECAUSE
IT SHOWS THAT MOVEMENT WAS
POLITICAL AND WAS NOT ABOUT ALL
WOMEN, IT WAS ABOUT TO PROMOTING
DEMOCRATIC WOMEN WHO ARE ABLE TO